what is this whole thing where you feel
like you could just
tell me how to live my life and always
command me
to do your bidding but you've never even
once asked me how i'm doing he just
talks at you yes i was like you always
talk at me you don't ever speak to me
what if what do you think gives you the
right to speak to me that way especially
i'm grown now i pay all my own [ __ ]
bills i in fact i help you guys out too
so it's like i'm not telling you that
you owe me anything but
in
five
four
three
two one what's up everybody welcome to
another episode of the genius brain
podcast i'm your host david so and once
again we have ed parkvp people are
texting me shut the [ __ ] up cheers
we have ourselves some fancy soju right
now it's supposed to be the [ __ ]
and that is smooth as hell this is the
smoothest soju i've ever had in my
[ __ ] life yeah wow this is really
good
shot
oh this is damn good dude my pinky's out
right now
oh
called mirror
and where'd you get it i got it from uh
a pachinko gift set all right um they
sent me a quick little little gift thing
for a promotion and of course justin
chan's uh directing book yeah a few
episodes and then we have annie chang um
being the dp for a few you know if you
guys don't know who they are justin chan
is my beady rat eyed little friend
you know
i [ __ ] love this guy [ __ ] the film
we're talking about miss purple blue
bayou i used to do his youtube videos
like 10 years ago dude people don't even
know that [ __ ] it's when i was big you
could see me in the old ones and i'm
like pretty pretty chunky dude if you
guys just go back look at justin chan
and look at his uh old youtube videos
they're the weirdest sketches you'll
ever see in your [ __ ] life
like
so [ __ ] weird there's this one sketch
that you guys did that had me [ __ ]
dying because of how odd it was and it
was when henry was
[Laughter]
yo what the [ __ ] was that
explain that [ __ ] to me
the thing is we always had normal skits
right for justin's youtube and back in
the day because you know he's homies
with um kev jumba and ryan higa
and they had the same formula and they
were pushing justin to start his own
youtube and she said just do our formula
yeah right so when justin came to town
in seattle and he
that's when i first met him we kicked it
off so good that he [ __ ] flew back to
seattle just so we could film youtube's
kids so he was living in seattle for a
week with us yeah
and so we filmed like 12 skits in a week
and then he flew back and i just edited
them for him that's why
his old youtube is always in seattle
it's because he flew up there too take
him with us it was so random so random
so
the script is normal as hell right just
like like you know youthful like oh
don't you hate it when this and then
it's a vlog at first and you skip to a
skit then you jump back to the vlog then
you do a skit right but that's a format
we just started [ __ ] with the format
just to be outside of the box but our
like mantra was also
how dumb can we be and get away with it
right
dude how stupid can we be on purpose we
got to start doing these stupid sketches
again man like the literally just
talking [ __ ] and then doing sketches
just follows the talking [ __ ] part yeah
is the funnest [ __ ] ever dude yeah dude
do you remember the dumbest the one of
the dumbest sketches that he and i ever
did it's so [ __ ] stupid it's
literally about me shoving my [ __ ]
dick in somebody's face after i beat
them like playing games
the street fighter
dude i was like wait what oh that's
right this
is hella funny bro
i looked back at that i was like damn i
made this like it was after effects on
it like i was like oh [ __ ] like because
if you guys know my story i had to go
back home after i lived here and i had
to work at a gas station for like four
years
and like i'm really rusty on after
effects and all that i was watching that
skit i was like damn that was good maybe
i can do that again you know it's it's i
literally wrote that thing just based on
a on a fat joke that somebody used to
say to me
they said that david's korean so he's
not ihonda we have to call him hyundai
that's good that's such a good dish and
i literally built the whole sketch off
of that one disc
this one called me hyundai and i
i remember
that's [ __ ] good yeah
when he said that [ __ ] dude i busted up
laughing so [ __ ] hard because of how
good the roast was
like
you can't call david hodd that he's
crazy
like dog that's [ __ ] hilarious oh my
god who the [ __ ] said that [ __ ] to me
but of course it was like a korean guy
but i don't remember who said that who
said that to me but that [ __ ] hurt my
feelings so bad but like you and then
you owned it
[Laughter]
but you know like when somebody makes
fun of you
even if it hurts your feelings if it's
hella funny i'm gonna die laughing
because it's just too [ __ ] funny yeah
like i
like when i'm when my i can't grow side
side burns and so it just grows like
really long yeah and then you know my
friend says that i they said they had
they had to pixelate the side of my face
because i have japanese [ __ ]
pubes
this was like this was japanese [ __ ]
hair
and i looked at him i was like what do
you mean it's like a japanese girl's
[ __ ] uh [ __ ] hair is always straight
and that's what your [ __ ] looks like a
dog
that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] had me i cried laughing
because of how good that roast was dude
saying that my sideburns looks like
japanese [ __ ] has one of the [ __ ]
most offensive things i've ever in my
life especially as a korean man yeah
if you converted to like an orthodox jew
and you had to grow that [ __ ] out and be
like
i'm sorry my [ __ ] doesn't curl
this guy's really long ass hair
and i never noticed i couldn't grow
sideburns until he said that [ __ ] i was
like oh i can't grow sideburns at all
it'll be like one hair on my cheek yeah
but i don't have much facial hair to
begin with so i've never been able to
grow facial hair at all
this [ __ ] came later in my life oh
yeah well your [ __ ] facial hair is
red red yeah that's another thing that's
why my mom was like yeah i asked her
about doing 23 and me yeah i do want to
do uh you know like dna tests and she's
like why she goes you're mongolian
yeah
yeah look at you look at you look at
your dad he was like dark skinned curly
hair right and you have red facial hair
yeah like all these aspects i was like
oh did i have that blue the birthmark on
my butt she's like yeah you had that too
when you were born yeah is that because
i've had that too i had the blue
birthmark too apparently that's that
mongolian tag yeah that's a kangaskhan
tag what is the story behind genghis
khan is when he he literally just
conquered and just [ __ ] a bunch of
women uh literally raped okay yeah
that's what that is so that's the thing
about it it's really weird to celebrate
him because he is like one of the
history's greatest like conquerors but
along the way he literally raped every
single woman he ever saw jesus i had no
idea i thought he was just marrying a
bunch of people that he was conquering
no he was just i think the statistic is
like two percent of the world's
population has kangaskhan dna
that's [ __ ] it's like that crazy dude
this guy was [ __ ] horny man
that is important like deviantly horny
oh let me ask you this
so
how often let's see let's say for you
right
let's say you are i don't like you have
a girlfriend now and the the girlfriend
is just down to have sex as many times
as you want every week how often would
you have sex
every week
unless they say not in the beginning in
the beginning it's you know in the
beginning it's all the time yeah but
let's say like you know two years in how
often do you think you would have sex
you know uh that another factor is age
yeah um
but
kind of like
yeah
the last
like interactions that i can think of is
probably maybe
three times a week yeah yeah because i
remember at 1.2 it was bad like i just
wasn't feeling it one day and she felt
crazy like unattractive really yeah and
it wasn't her fault it's just like i
just wasn't feeling it that day yeah
did she just look like you'd be like you
don't want sex with me
i've been doing you a favor this whole
time i know i i feel [ __ ] terrible
about it like it's it's but it's not her
fault you know she's over you're just
like excuse me
dude my libido though changes with my
diet like when i fast i really don't
[ __ ] at all like i don't feel like i
think about sex let me tell you
something when i work out a lot sex is
not on the table yeah i'm tired
i freaking told y'all dude like i'm
tired i'm sleepy you know that's why
when people work out a lot and they they
say it boosts their libido it's i'm sore
don't touch me
i'm exhausted so the reason why i bring
that up is because i had a conversation
with a friend of mine
and
um
he was talking about how
he
likes to have a lot of sex
right and
he if he had it his way he would have
sex two to three times a day every day
right and i'm thinking like bro
you're gonna kill her [ __ ]
that [ __ ] hurts after a while you know i
was like are you doesn't your dick hurt
but then like there's those people with
like those crazy
um
claims that they like will chamberlain
right like how many women said like over
his lifetime oh it was like a ridiculous
tens of thousands of [ __ ] like that
yeah and i remember back in the day i
was reading this um what is it uh fhm or
maxim maxum maxim i read it for the
articles bro
no but there was this like top 10 list
right yeah of claimed like men of how
many sexual counters they had and i
think number one was like charlie shane
right like he has what's his age though
doesn't he yeah he's hate people yeah or
some [ __ ] but that was the things
because he would have massive orchids
for months on end
how is that possible or maybe i've just
never had like a really strong libido
because i'm not i'm not that horny
like i'm not i'm not motivated by sex
like that at all right
if i look at let me pl like as a
heterosexual male if i you know if a
girl walks by she has a fat ass
yeah i'm like oh my word
what in the mount montezuma is that you
know
i was like look at those cakes like yeah
i'll look and you know i'll flirt and
stuff but it's it has never been my
objective to always try to get in the
girl's pants like i just never cared
that much right yeah if i you know if
i'm a lover boy so if i'm in love with
somebody i want to have sex with them
but it's just like
random hookups i'm not saying i didn't
have them right because you know when
you go through a dry spell and you're a
young person you're going to want to
have sex but
i thought that i was you know decently
sexually active i was not yeah compared
to everybody else when i hear their
number yeah i'm like dude your number's
high like some of my friends too i'm
just like what the [ __ ] i think it is
like for me too like i never went on
friday nights like i'm gonna [ __ ]
that never came to my mind it was just
i'm gonna get [ __ ] up yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah like you know when people go
out they're trying to smash all the time
yeah are you not afraid of aids yeah
when i met those guys too like who they
want to go to belasco because they're
trying to vlog and i'm like
that's why you go out like that was
beyond maybe it's the church boys and uh
it might be that it might be the
christian church voice
but that was a lot of church boys that
weren't like us though
you know but maybe because we were like
in it right you know what i mean because
i remember too like i remember when i
lost my virginity i i was gambling with
the thought of am i going to go to hell
yeah
do you think every guy is like oh [ __ ]
yeah i was like am i
if i
dive deep into this [ __ ]
is god gonna not love me yeah you know
yeah and the next thing you know i had
sex
and then you did it again
oh i'm still here yeah
god forgives yeah
you know he's good
all the time
that christian guilt was so nuts because
i even remember when i was a kid because
i curse a lot now
and the reason why i started cursing a
lot more number one i enjoy the way of
expression yes it just emphasizes things
really well and it's fun it's funny to
me obviously in front of small children
i'm not going to do that i'm very good
with that depending you know on who the
person is and i'll bring up another
story about that later um
but
i remember when i said [ __ ] yeah it was
i can't remember what age it was it had
to be when i was like seven or eight
yeah i went [ __ ] and i felt that satan
grabbed my ankles and he was dragging me
to the center of hell i remember i was
did you see ghosts just before you're
not at the end of ghosts yeah i like
dragons
i legit
thought that i was going to hell every
time i said the f word
and that was that christian guilt that
would eat me up inside yeah and then
later on so you say
fruit
frick frick
biscuit yeah
and it never felt good right and the
funny thing is is like there was this
moment where i had such a you know bad
issue with my temper as a kid mainly
because i was getting bullied and the
way that we would solve issues when we
were younger is through physical bodies
get out and get out and it's just not
very healthy so
i legit remember
in seventh grade i was so [ __ ] angry
right i developed this habit of instead
of cursing i would just punch [ __ ] until
my hand would go numb oh my gosh over
and over and over again that teenage
angst man yeah what do you take it
where's my and you're in church exactly
it's like is it a sin to destroy some
drywall
so i
i got so [ __ ] mad and i remember i i
went to this uh middle school called
james rutter out in uh sacramento and
there was this guy his name was uh let's
call him sean this guy named sean
um which who i heard an update from now
he is in jail
nice so this guy
flunked
twice yeah or and he was okay he didn't
flunk twice what i found out recently
because i've been telling people that he
flunked twice it wasn't that he flunked
twice he got into uh kindergarten during
that weird time where his birthday is
yeah where you have to either be held
back or contin so he was that a year
older and then on top of that he flunked
so he was two years older than everybody
else this full look damn near looked
like a ta yeah you know
so i was dumb as [ __ ] very very [ __ ]
athletic though yeah well the problem
with him
was that this fool would always try to
punk people
and
steal their homework
let's keep this podcast supported and
going my friends and check out the lost
debate do you feel like you're living in
a media bubble like it's harder than
ever to find views that challenge your
own that's where the lost debate steps
in is a podcast and youtube show for
political eclectics who crave exposure
to a diversity of beliefs and
perspectives because everybody
especially the news lady are all about
trends and shoving their biases down
your throat and just beating you down
with manipulation from mainstream
[ __ ] well guess what let's just have
some honest conversations ravi gupta
corey bradford and ricky schlatt my
friends they come from across the
political aisle from different
generations and guess what fun [ __ ] dope
[ __ ] great conversations join the
conversation check out the lost debate
today new episodes drop tuesday and
thursdays find the lost debate on
youtube apple pop apple podcast spotify
or wherever you get your shows
yeah really take my homework erase your
name yeah and i remember this moment too
cause like he was trying to take my [ __ ]
and you know geeky asian kid with you
know coke bottle glasses split little
penis head yeah you know you know the
penis hair
the parted bowl yeah the part of volca
where it just looks like a [ __ ] dick
and did you have some bangs a little bit
oh yeah
yeah so i was doing that and then he
tried to take my paper and i grabbed it
from it and i was like hey what are you
doing he was like i'm gonna take your
[ __ ] homework i'm like no you're not
and so literally
i mean he wasn't very tall but i was
this height already yeah at like 13.
yeah so you know maybe like a couple
inches shorter than i am now i remember
i stood up and he was like oh [ __ ] this
kid's really [ __ ] big but he's two
years older yeah and then we get into a
fight in the middle of class he's saying
he's gonna [ __ ] me up and the teacher
saw what happened she knows that he's a
troublemaker i go outside and i there's
like a uh you know the water fountains
and i just started smashing my fish into
the water fountain right because i
didn't get the fight it was broken up
yeah and then my hand was mangled
and then i just looked at my hand and
then i remembered the teacher's name was
mr fontes and he looked at me he's like
what did you do to your hands like i'm
just
so [ __ ] angry like you didn't let me
fight like i hit it you know he goes i
understand you know like i saw that he
provoked you but you got to learn how to
express yourself differently yeah right
and also he goes you know try doing it
through your words worst advice ever he
gave to me
[ __ ] all over the place now yeah saying
[ __ ] [ __ ] damn [ __ ] whatever all that
[ __ ] and it made me feel better it makes
you feel better because you really mean
what you're feeling in your heart right
yeah that's the kind of [ __ ] i i said a
lot in church too because um like i said
we grew up with a lot of american like
white and black people in our church
because of the military base and they
all had korean wives
so they do a lot of like good handiwork
right around the church and whatever
i remember like
like my half white friends and their
dads or dad would always cuss to them
right and i'd be like
right
but then my friend later explained to me
he was just like look man like
if you really mean it in your heart
like if in your heart you have all this
anger and hatred and then you say frick
like what do you really mean in your
heart anyway like jesus knows right yeah
so he goes if you're gonna sin and your
heart is already that way he said
hundred percent just say it
you looked at him and you went [ __ ] yeah
yeah
[Laughter]
so but
later it was solidified in iraq actually
so when i was in iraq like i mentioned
before i was a missionary out there
we were walking around town
and we see this white dude in this park
right and you know like that's just rare
we're the only other non um like kurdish
people out there
and instantly he just comes and walks to
us and he's like hey what are you guys
doing here and then we like oh we're
part of an ngo and
that we don't know what's going on
um
it's like a
not it's a literal term for a bad i
don't remember okay okay
but it's kind of like a non-profit kind
of thing like yeah we're helping out the
schools we're doing this and that
and then um he just says it's like oh
yeah i'm a missionary he's not even
scared right so like oh yeah we are too
you know okay
and then we just kept it real and had a
real talk and this guy was cussing and
dropping f-bombs like all the time right
and i was so drawn to that and i was
listening even closer to him because he
really meant what he was talking about
and his whole story was like
after 9 11 he became a christian
and he dug he just had this massive
crisis like of his existence and his
faith
and so he just like we dug deep into the
word went to the deep end and then he's
the same reason he saw
we as americans started invading iraq
you know and yeah destroying and killing
him so he went there for the same
reasons
but he was out there and he was keeping
it [ __ ] real and that that showed me
a lot too like what keeping it real
means so yeah yeah okay i'm gonna just
be me and express myself from the heart
because if i i still do care about these
people
but um like obviously i'm not gonna be
vulgar around like because a lot of them
are like very wholesome muslim people of
course but i'll i'll try to read the
crowd because i
live there now right i just have to have
the social cues so that changed up my
whole attitude towards like cussing and
just keeping it [ __ ] real
really yeah that's so crazy mine was
literally just for therapy it was like
it just feels good i gotta stop punching
things yeah like i gotta release this
anger somewhere else and it was just
saying
[ __ ]
damn
yeah
ass
and the funny thing is like you know
what really solidified it for me even
more
it's like my mom was like don't curse
me
literally what she's saying to me in
korean is like hey don't curse you [ __ ]
listen [ __ ] don't talk to me
that way yeah i'm like
he's like
[Music]
[Music]
words in front of me you stupid
bitch-ass [ __ ] i'm like hold on
a second you know it doesn't matter what
language you're saying it's still curse
words dude
oh my my dad had a [ __ ] up like idea
that [ __ ] because you know
uh ex-gang member had a rough life and
upbringing i heard him cuss a lot
growing up too
but then um
once we hit like uh middle school high
school he started really trying to like
change up and fix up his life and get to
work and like
kind of he lectured us a lot
but then he didn't know [ __ ]
[Laughter]
so one time
i was i was at the store we were working
i think i pinched my finger
right and i was like oh what the heck
right he's like more no more myself i
said what the heck he's like
what the heck and i was like yeah what
the heck
he literally thought it was like an
american curse word you know what i'm
saying it's hilarious like no this is
like a replacement for a curse yeah it's
like
this is a good word
this is it's not bad yeah he got [ __ ]
pissed at me what the heck
same [ __ ] with me when i was um
i was helping my mom because
i didn't like working at the store on
saturdays because those are the days i
wanted for myself yeah but you know as a
korean you know immigrant kid you have
to work whatever your parents tell you
to work so i'm working on all my
weekends yeah all my weekends were there
it's summer break so i was having like a
pissy ass mood in the morning
but by the time i got to the store i was
perfectly fine right i'm like whatever
it's fine i'm here i got my game boy
i'll play my game boy in between
so i'm going to the store and my mom has
me um
a box full of like food that we have
right so it was a cardboard box but she
put like toshibak in there yeah like
lunch stuff and then as i was opening
the door i went to go grab the door but
the door slammed on my fingers i was
like [ __ ]
ah and my mom was like
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
[ __ ]
yeah
your [ __ ]
and all she just knew she assumed that i
was being upset because i had to go to
work but just look at my purple [ __ ]
fingers oh my gosh you know and then so
she just starts wailing on me
look at my hand
she doesn't give a [ __ ] she starts
beating the [ __ ] out of me and then
after it's all said and done she's just
like lecturing me for hours and then
she's like what's wrong with your hand
yeah like i smashed my fingers that's my
car she goes oh
you already beat the [ __ ] out of me dude
you know what's done is done
dude there's so many parents that like
completely misunderstand what the [ __ ]
you're like you're doing
like all the [ __ ] time like ah
there's so many instances
in my life where my parents thought um
i was doing one thing and they literally
thought i was supposed to be doing
another like even uh oh [ __ ] so my dad
finally he didn't come to my graduation
in high school because he was in jail
yeah right and then uh when i graduated
college though he came up and um
they're announcing the names by um each
major so there's like audio there's
fashion and then they announce um video
production and they call my name after
the graduation my dad was so [ __ ]
pissed at me he said you went to school
for video
and i'm like yes
she's like i thought you went to art
school for drawing for illustration oh
my god and i'm like damn you don't talk
to me
that much
you don't even know what my major was
and you're mad at me about it
that's hilarious
yeah that's [ __ ] like are are you on
the same plane
wait so what did they expect that you to
do after well because when i was a kid i
was i used to illustrate a lot yeah a
lot like my uncle has this um portrait i
drew of him when i was like in fourth
grade and i saw it again once i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i drew that
yeah yeah yeah and um but by the time i
got into high school i just stopped
doing it i actually just got into video
so the whole time my dad thought i was
going there for like animation or
illustration yeah and he knew okay at
least you can get a job you might work
at disney or something he's like what
the [ __ ] are you gonna do in video
and i'm like there's
you care about it now like after my
graduation not like when i went to
school dude we've there's just so many
funny just random like miscommunication
stuff that we had especially because and
i'm pretty sure a lot of kids who are
immigrants who have parents who don't
speak english there's a big breakdown in
communication because we don't speak the
language each other's languages right
right so our my me and my dad's
relationship got better once i started
to learn how to be korean
because i just didn't know like there
would be moments too when my dad's
screaming at me in korean and my dad is
just turning blue in the face yeah right
and then he just looks at me and he he
just knows that he doesn't understand a
damn word i'm saying and then he looks
at my brother tell him what i just said
and then my brother was like okay this
is what he's telling you and i'm like
okay
but he's just like so frustrated because
he can't even communicate to me what the
[ __ ] i'm [ __ ] up on yeah you know
dude my dad started speaking english
when we got into some i got into seventh
grade so uh my brother is like a year
older so he's an eighth
and like i said he would do these
lectures and he started speaking english
to us for the first time in our lives
and it was so [ __ ] bad we could
hardly like understand what the [ __ ] he
is saying
dude did you ever get those things where
your dad would learn like a one specific
english word and he would use it all the
time
my dad would always do that [ __ ] so it
would be some weird [ __ ] he learned the
word actually
actually
all the [ __ ] time but he would use it
to insult me
yeah no actually he goes like i should
this is not even me embellishing
anything and making a joke i i will
forever remember what he did because i
just kept on hearing him say this word
actually because he learned from my
friend sam's dad and he would always say
egg shooty
right
and so
this [ __ ]
like i would do so i did i forgot what
exactly i did but he goes actually you
are the stupid
i'm like this [ __ ] doesn't speak
english yeah and he just outright just
uses his first word he learns and calls
me dumb right i mean is there a korean
word for actually i don't know could
it's all
oh my god the times my dad would [ __ ]
call me dumb or pyongshin or [ __ ] so
once
as a kid i actually didn't know what it
meant
my dad would call me pyeongchin like all
the time
right so one day was your korean name
how come every knows my name
yeah
no so i was at the store and i was like
really asking i was like
what's a pyeongchang
right
she's like where she's like papa calls
me that all the time she was like what
what
she was like pyongshin is littar
i didn't even know
she meant [ __ ] i thought it just meant
you were slow or dumb yeah and so my
whole life i thought there are so many
things korean dramas taught me like i'm
gonna used to call me that [ __ ] too you
know dude korean people are so harsh
with their words yeah like you could
just mess up something small punction
i am [ __ ]
because i dropped my chopstick yeah
hilarious dude yeah those those words
and well i guess it's good that we
didn't really speak korean that well
anyways because it would have affected
me a lot more if i if it was my truly my
first language because it would impact
me a lot more yeah but
genius brain listeners this podcast is
brought to you by ipvanish my genius
brain farts did you know that browsing
online using incognito mode doesn't
actually protect your privacy that's
right without added security you might
as well give away all your private data
to hackers advertisers your isp and
other prying eyes you freaking idiots
what are you doing you need to get
ipvanish i don't surf [ __ ]
if i'm not using my vpn from ipvanish
and if you think i am you would be wrong
steal these nuts [ __ ] even your
physical location will be hidden
ipvanish makes you virtually invisible
online whatever you look up is your
business and everybody trying to be in
your business need to get out your
business and ipvanish got your back
ipvanish is offering an incredible 70
off their yearly plan for our listeners
with a 30 day money back guarantee
that's like getting 9 months for free so
go to ipvanish.com
brain and use promotional code brain and
claim your seventy percent savings
that's ipva and ish dot com slash brain
i would hear words like
you know which albeit given i did a lot
of stupid [ __ ] yeah but you shouldn't
say that to your kids
you know
like after a while you're kind of
sitting there and i remember like
pyeongchang i found it [ __ ] because
i was watching korean dramas in college
and it translated it yeah i'm like wait
that means [ __ ]
you've been calling me [ __ ] my whole
life what the [ __ ] my dad called me my
grandma called me that yeah i'm like
what is this [ __ ] dude like i remember
me calling my mom because i was learning
all these curse words in these cringe
i'm like oh my you you call me [ __ ]
my whole life she goes yeah i'm like
you you can't call i'm your son like you
don't say that stuff to me listen well
sorry man i can call you that because
you're my son i know right anybody else
says that yeah that's the problem yeah
right i just had this conversation with
her recently where we were talking on
the phone
and she's just
so you know my knee's a little [ __ ] up
but i'm rehabbing it and i'm working on
it right yeah and my knee has gotten a
lot better than the last couple weeks
but she keeps calling me about my
[ __ ] knee because you know parents
are always going to worry about you no
matter how old you are yeah and then i
literally told my mom i was like
so let me let me let me get this is like
you're gonna constantly call me three
four times a day to ask me about my knee
just like
waiting for it to get healed yeah i'm
like you're stressing me out like guys
if you can read your health meter
exactly i'm like i what i told you two
hours ago is the same hello baby what's
your hp level
did you pie the final boss
but she's checking up on me which is
very sweet but i literally told her i
was like hey
i'm old now yeah you don't need to check
up on me she goes listen i don't care
how old you are when i when i call you
you pick up the phone and you hear me
complain yeah i was like what do you
mean she goes if i want to complain and
nag at you you're just going to have to
listen right because i don't care
you're a guy yeah i'm like i i guess
that's just the deal yeah you know so i
just kind of pick up the phone and i'm
like oh i don't care she goes okay i'm
still gonna say it
she didn't give a [ __ ] about my feelings
dude yeah she called me a [ __ ] for a
[ __ ] 30 years of my life dude i mean
i think the
the relationship i had with my mom was
that i was able to keep it real with her
right like
there was once
like my mom wanted me to have lunch with
her after church this whole time all
morning at church i was just hung over
right and even all all the way up to me
having lunch with her i could like
barely sit up she's like what's wrong
with you are you sick and i was able to
keep it real it's just like i'm i'm
[ __ ] hungover like i am so hungry i
drank too much last night you know she
says to me she goes edward
you have to be careful because you have
my blood
my family can drink
oh
okay i got i thought she was gonna be
like you can't drink
you're you're a bible study teacher all
these things she's just just careful
with it they they like i i
i mean i know a lot of people they see
the glimpse of korean culture that
people see and once again when we speak
about korean culture we're talking about
our korean american experience and you
know what people experience in korea are
probably going to be really different so
i'm not really speaking for that part
i'm only talking about our lives and a
lot of korean americans can really
relate to this stuff but you know just
going back to what we were saying about
how sometimes like korean people don't
understand how harsh words can be yeah
like um i got really drunk one time and
i was i threw up so much i popped the
blood vessels in my eyes
and so i legit thought i was gonna die
and i went into the shower it was fully
clothed and i just hit the shower
just moaning and i could just hear my
dad and my own what's wrong what's wrong
i was like i drank and i didn't really
drink that much at that time
i drank a lot when i was younger but
there was a good few period a few years
where i didn't drink yeah and so my mom
is like worried about me she goes you
have to take you to the hospital and my
dad i can hear him screaming in the back
let him die
you know
he made his choices let him die i'm
gonna drive him to the hospital leave
him at the front he's gonna die anyways
let him die oh my god my mom's like
she's gonna tell me shut up
i can't hear him you know shut up my
dad's like if he wants to die just let
him die oh my god that's too dramatic
man that's what you get for drunken yeah
he's just screaming at the top of his
[ __ ] lungs and my dad's so chill now
right he's really [ __ ] chill you know
because of you and you're talking about
how your whole um your whole family life
and
your your your experiences i i went to
go talk to
um
my uh my dad about my grandpa all your
family history right you told me you're
gonna say like open up about that yeah
grandpa and grandma and i and i
mentioned this a little bit earlier with
um who the [ __ ] was i talking to
somebody on this damn podcast i think it
was uh edric but
when i was a kid i didn't know that my
grandparents could speak um japanese oh
that was with me yeah you did you did
tell me that yeah they could speak
japanese completely fluently and then um
what it was is that
um during uh world war ii you know
because we were occupied by japan even
before that yeah from like 1910 yeah it
was like a good 50 years or something
like that we had a long occupation right
and you know that terrible history but
my grandpa
um could read and write and speak in
japanese
so his position was like in the middle
he would he would do paperwork for
korean people translating their [ __ ]
so he would like
switch over korean documents over into
japanese and so you know he wasn't
really [ __ ] with my grandma was a
military translator for the military for
the japanese military because she could
speak japanese as well completely
fluently read and write right so when
military japanese people would do i
don't know whatever it's a general i'm
making this up right now but they would
do a speech or they had to tell people
korean people to go somewhere
she would translate it in korean right
right to these people right so that's
that's why they spoke japanese and
when i was a kid they would um
talk [ __ ]
in japanese so we couldn't understand
right so they were just getting fights
and it'd just be loud all in japanese
and then my dad told me he's like you
don't remember when your grandma and
grandpa would fight in front of us and
it would just be all in japanese right i
was like oh [ __ ] like i don't remember
too much but i do remember my grandpa
showing me that he could speak and write
in japanese yeah very interesting and
just because like we were talking about
some verbal abuse [ __ ]
um you know our buddy ray
told me that he he remembered his
grandma and grandpa speaking japanese
yeah
only because as a kid because he used to
watch a lot of anime and he would always
hear his name with rey
and [ __ ] baca which is idiot
japanese
but they didn't know that he understood
that they were like
[Applause]
a kid
what the [ __ ]
korean people are hella [ __ ] verbally
abusive dude oh [ __ ] and his grandpa too
i actually found out about his
grandfather his grandfather was high up
military for for both sides
wow so during um you know while they
were uh you know while japan occupied
korea yeah he was in like the japanese
military and he was a higher up like a
general like either like in the navy or
some [ __ ] i forgot what it was but then
when obviously then when world war ii
happened he was a higher up in the
military for in korea
which is so [ __ ] nuts to me yeah
blows my mind and these are the things
that we don't ever fit i never cared to
ask yeah and i finally asked my dad and
it's like i asked him too and about this
period where um i was like well what
happened during the korean war like did
it huddle with you like no he [ __ ] he
was on a boat he went to an island and
he fished and he'd even know the war
ended
until like somebody you know fishermen
came up to be like what the [ __ ] are
these people doing here on this island
yeah the war's done
oh my god i was like oh so he was just
fishing the whole time and that's where
my grandpa fell in love with fishing so
my grandpa would fish every [ __ ]
weekend like deep sea fishing
all the time so he fell in love with
fishing while he escaped the korean war
as he was fishing off these small
islands and then he continued that on
right which is so [ __ ] crazy yeah
that's [ __ ] crazy like my i remember
my uh grandparents both spoke japanese
too that's the thing every korean
grandparent yeah it speaks japanese
we're only like two generations away
from yeah it's an occupation yeah
um but
what i
learned uh was that
when my grandma was 16
her best friend was kidnapped as a sex
slave
oh yeah [ __ ] yeah
and so
they
and i told you my grandma's uh father
was a politician and so they had
connections
um so this is the
1930s i believe like where
they
they had to reach out to a family friend
who was my grandfather he was a scholar
he was a korean living in japan as a
scholar yeah and then they called him
back to korea to marry my grandma so
that she won't get kidnapped as a sex
life holy [ __ ] yeah so that's why they
got married like at such a young age
for real yeah just to avoid that that's
why that [ __ ] is like i mean thank
[ __ ] god my money isn't you know like
didn't become one of those sex ladies
but it's real to her too like her best
friend and you know we talked about
earlier like way back when we're talking
about chingu like friends in korea is
[ __ ] deep-seated because you go
through the entire public school system
in the same class as the same people
they say it's best friends for life my
dad's still best friends with his with
his friend in korea and they still talk
over facebook and [ __ ] he's like no yeah
so when like my perception of what a
best friend is compared to our parents
was very different so different they
spent ever almost every waking second
with them aside from the fact when they
went home but at school from elementary
school all up until you know high school
like they've probably been in the same
class together yeah i'm not sure how it
is nowadays but
that is how it is for them my
80-year-old grandma called me from korea
when i had kakao i deleted that [ __ ] but
when i yeah she's like i'm in korea i'm
with my elementary school friends that's
so crazy [ __ ] 80 years old you know
she goes back to korea connect it's easy
to connect with them because of where
they're from dude
and i would hear some of these crazy
stories too because i don't know what
it's like for them in elementary school
but you know we would always see these
korean shows and you see like a certain
amount of bullying and stuff but then my
mom told me that i mean i'm pretty sure
films ex obviously films exaggerated a
lot of fight scenes or whatever yeah but
my mom was talking about like how
bullying was when she was a kid and she
was like girls were really mean
um in her grade school so my mom was
always like a tomboy and she said that
you know
so my mom has this condition where it's
not
it's just crazy condition called
alopecia no
she has this condition where she can't
sweat
she physically cannot sweat so her body
doesn't have a mechanism to cool her
body down so when we when we were kids
and we would go to these you know church
volleyball tournaments yes in the summer
it's hot as [ __ ] i had to put ice packs
on the back of her neck so she would
stay cool because she physically cannot
sweat wow so um with my mom
a lot of kids make fun of her because
her face would turn red right because
she's just heating up inside yeah so
they would call her tomato
you know they try to roast her ass well
my mom had a and you know when my mom
looks at me and she goes i don't
understand where you get this violence
from it's like it's from you [ __ ]
so this is a story that her friend told
me was like she one time these guys were
picking on her so much that they kept on
calling her tomato face over and over
and the whole class would laugh
she was like she tried to befriend them
and she started being like kind of
flirty with them or whatever you know
just to kind of ease it and then she was
like oh let's meet up after school and
you know kind of like have some fun or
whatever yeah she beat the [ __ ] out of
these two guys oh my god
like literally jumped them behind us
behind the school oh [ __ ] because they
kept calling her tomato face
like this woman is a savage and this
isn't from her this is from her my mom's
friend telling me the story i'm like
jesus what the [ __ ] and then she looks
at me and goes
why are you so
it's like
she's a [ __ ] buddha yeah but you know
all these parents have these back
stories that you don't know but
other people will fill it in yeah you
know abe's dad so
abe is my uh my manager also my cousin
i've i've known
him as his dad is a hard ass i love him
he's my uncle right right
hard ass and i never understood why he
would use to use to wake us up in
saturday mornings and just call us
jackasses
right
he was a lazy dude
why aren't you up bunch of lazy dudes
you bunch of idiots and he was saying in
english because he's he's americanized
yeah right because he came to the states
when he was in junior high wow well
um
abe told me this funny [ __ ] story
where he was i think he was at a bank i
don't remember what exactly it was but
he was at a bank and because he used to
work for the bank and then he was he
looked at abe because abe looks like his
dad and he saw his last name and he goes
oh is your
father's name this and that yeah he goes
yeah that's my dad how do you know him
he goes dude your dad was a [ __ ]
badass in high school he's like what do
you mean how is he a badass he goes yeah
well your dad used to get into a lot of
[ __ ] fights he goes what is your dad
up to now you know my dad uh works works
for the uh for the for folsom state
prison he goes oh you mean he's in
prison
no no he works as a teacher as an
educator inside the folsom state prison
no you mean he's in jail
he goes no he's not in jail he is he
teaches there and then lo and behold i
started hearing these stories from him
because we kind of asked him about it
during thanksgiving
this fall was known specifically in
sacramento elk grove california as the
dude that would carry around nunchucks
with him
he had like long flowy air yeah [ __ ] too
yeah long flowy [ __ ] hair and he was
like
jacket
nunchucks and so he told me this story
and he's telling the story like it's all
casual he goes yeah i remember you know
at the time elk grove was really white
and i was one of the only asian kids
that was in the football team and i
wasn't scared of anybody so i went to a
party and somebody called me a [ __ ] so
i decided to get my nunchucks and i
smashed all their windows
dude that is not an appropriate response
bro my gosh
he was laughing his ass off i'm like
dude you're a criminal
found a way to beat the system though
he would [ __ ] people up with these pair
of [ __ ] wood nunchucks and nunchucks
are illegal
genius farts you know what time it is
thank you for listening to our sponsors
and supporting them because without you
guys i don't get paid and i gotta be out
in these streets sucking some ding dong
which hey for some people they might
like it but not for me so this podcast
is brought to you by raycon my friends a
lot of people didn't even make
resolutions this year and you know what
i get it but that doesn't mean you
shouldn't still find a way to shake
things up whether it's by switching up
your workout routine or going someplace
new whatever way you challenge yourself
this new year there's no better way to
do it than with a pair of recon wireless
earbuds in your ears their everyday
earbuds look feel and sound better than
ever i freaking love them if i'm outside
i'm jogging i'm shadow boxing i got
myself my raycon earbuds in they don't
fall out my damn ears and let me tell
you something your boy be shaking and
rumbling all over the place specifically
when i am biking i love my raycon
earbuds they feel freaking amazing
raycons offer eight hours of play time
and a 32 hour battery life that's right
so when you do these domestic flights
from here to california all the way to
new york i don't want to worry about it
running out of freaking batteries which
is so damn annoying it's no wonder
raycon's everyday earbuds have over 48
000 five-star reviews right now genius
brain listeners can get 15 off their
recon order at
dot com slash brain that's by raycon dot
com slash brain to say 15 on ray cons by
recon dot com slash brain yeah and he
would always carry carry them in his
back pocket but apparently this fool
would just walk around in his asian gang
and just start [ __ ] people up as a
menace oh my gosh and i'm just like what
is what are who are you i don't know who
you are yeah but now i understand why he
would beat my ass all the time because
he was such a hard ass you know like i
look back through like like um you were
mentioning the old classmate you had was
two years older right and i told you my
dad was in seventh grade when he was 16
yeah and [ __ ] and so i had it in my head
he probably bullied the [ __ ] out of
everybody yeah the biggest person there
but um i remember one time when we were
in high school we we did a road trip to
l.a and he was driving us through k-town
and he drove by virgil high school and
he's like this is my high school this is
where i went
like wow you went to high school here in
america wow right so he's like in my
hand i'm like man my dad
walked through the same steps i did too
you know he's not that different and
then he's like
yeah teacher got raped there
what
what
like like a teacher raped a kid or
something he's like no
boy rape a man teacher
i was like the [ __ ] what i like how he
just casually just says things yeah he's
just casually just brought up i'm only
15 at this time i like it he just starts
breaking it down to you yeah he took up
his pants yeah
[Laughter]
but yeah he said it's so casually like
the [ __ ] did you live through you know
what kind of high school was this back
in the 70s i guess it was [ __ ] rough
a lot of these like asian gangs too
started up because of bullying yeah all
the time like they had to kind of stick
together so people just wouldn't [ __ ]
with them and you know
you know 90s and 80s and stuff like that
there was a lot of asian people were
getting profiled because of like a
highly gang affiliated [ __ ] yeah and the
way like
if i'm i'm pretty sure if you're if
you're like vietnamese cambodian
southeast asian and um your parents tell
you these stories or maybe even like
some of your older cousins and uncles
they'll probably tell you i mean
depending on who your relatives are but
this is like the the people that i knew
and kind of grew up around is that you
know they would tell stories about they
get bullied a lot and so they had to
stick together but the biggest
difference that a lot of like american
gangs didn't realize about people who
come from war-torn countries what you
did was child's play yeah like there was
you could look up these articles of
people [ __ ] getting their heads
chopped off with machetes yeah and
they're just like these are wearing
glasses yeah yeah it's like oh these
guys are crazy not crazy they grew up in
a war-torn country yeah you know what i
mean people were getting shot killed and
murdered you [ __ ] around with them
saying you're gonna [ __ ] them up to them
it's like
oh it's do or die i got to kill this
person yeah and they would literally
chop people's limbs off i'm not saying
everybody but there were very specific
stories just like that oh yeah like my
my friend got in a fight at the club
he's this with the vietnamese dude and
on the dance floor he straight body
slammed him right and when they got
outside they went at it again
but then the bouncers like beat the [ __ ]
out of my friend right they kicked him
in the face and he had a huge gash on
his oh [ __ ] yeah then my brother saw
what the [ __ ] happened so he walked
straight up to the vietnamese dude and
just
sucked in the face too then the bouncers
jumped on my brother and all this it was
[ __ ] panicking they knew each other
the bouncer knew each other for sure
maybe but
my friend couldn't hide the fact that he
had this
huge gash on his forehead now or on his
eyebrow right and then he had to go see
his dad
next day like church and then
but he had it he kept it real with his
dad too he's like i gotta fight you know
what you know this vietnamese kid you
know his dad said he's like oh don't
fight the vietnamese kids
they come from war
you know their parents and their country
that's very sad you should feel bad yeah
he's like a lot of war don't fight the
vietnamese like damn
yeah man like like these southeast um
asian refugee stories are so [ __ ]
nuts and it's not even that long ago
these are parents who have like
literally gone through that [ __ ] yeah
and so
you know sometimes when you know people
talk about their trials and tribulations
like i bet you ain't never talked to a
[ __ ] vietnamese refugee bro yeah like
they've been through some [ __ ] [ __ ]
like
you i mean one day you know khalif will
probably tell his story about his mom's
story too and it's so [ __ ] crazy just
just to think that somebody i've
physically seen
went through this
horrendous [ __ ] yeah you know and that's
why people you see a lot of like
vietnamese adoptees here yeah because
they came from a war-torn country
there's stories of people like giving
their children away to like you know
american people take my kid take my kid
because they're gonna die here and their
whole village gets obliterated right so
what do you do here you know like that's
those stories always
kind of
honestly just keep me in check yeah
because people they're still alive these
people are still it's fresh for them for
us it's like two generations apart
but then we do see the uh the residual
effects of our grandparents having seen
shh a lot of [ __ ] like um i mean uh
first episode of pachinko came out and
they really show what japanese
occupation in korea was like in the
early 1900s
right they really portrayed it like hard
like what the kind of
oppression like literally what was like
too and so that's why like i feel like
like koreans have
well a a different sense of humor
because of the [ __ ] they've seen but
also like kind of like i said an
emotional hardness right like we have we
can laugh about it now but the way our
parents are so emotionally cut off
because of what their parents went
through yeah it's like there's no
[ __ ] reason to complain about
anything because you're [ __ ] alive
yeah yeah yeah yeah i mean when the the
last fight that me and my dad had we had
a conversation about like and this was
years ago and then um
it was just a really
sad conversation about how i i basically
told him like yo you
never you was like you always like to
tell me what to do but you don't ever
talk to me yeah i was like what is this
whole thing where you feel like you
could just
tell me how to live my life and always
command me
to do your bidding but you've never even
once asked me how i'm doing he just
talks at you yes i was like you always
talk at me you don't ever speak to me
what
do what do you think gives you the right
to speak to me that way especially i'm
grown now i pay all my own [ __ ] bills
i in fact i help you guys out too so
it's like i'm not telling you that you
owe me anything but
why don't you ever just i don't know ask
me how i'm doing
my dad says something very profound he
goes because i don't know how he goes
i don't straight up he goes get the real
let me ask you something he goes do you
think that your grandparents your
grandma grandpa asked me how i was doing
because they never did yeah they asked
me the same questions did you eat yeah
what are you doing stop messing up he
goes this is all i know this is how i
know how to communicate because this is
all i was taught you're asking me to do
something i don't know how to do and
he's like you're never gonna get that
yeah you know it's not because i don't
want to i just don't know how he goes
you're at an age now and i'm at an age
where i'm not gonna change you can
change you need to learn how to
empathize with me and understand that
i've been through things that you don't
even know about so just
stop expecting me to be like your mom
like your mom is there for if you want
to talk about your feelings you know go
be gay with her
[Laughter]
you know
but you know like you have a parent that
can do that i can't do that for you you
know right so that was like a big
learning lesson for me too it's like ah
[ __ ] i need to learn how to empathize
with my parents because they just been
through [ __ ] that i haven't yeah and i'm
expecting them to kind of mold into this
you know american ideal of what a family
is but this is not something that they
grew up with so you know when you reach
a certain age it was you have to learn
how to empathize with your parents as
well you know yeah like my i could see
that in my dad too he never explained it
to us like
but knowing
like the the the memories i have of my
haraoji my dad's dad
like he was a hard like serious man he
was a military man who fought in vietnam
and
i can see like my money told me a story
how
when my harabaji would scold him or say
some [ __ ] it made my dad cry and that
blows my [ __ ] mind i was like what do
you mean you're my art he cried yeah my
dad he cried you know it's like where
yeah
so i can see like there because of
all of the
the type of neglect my dad had
it it seemed like um
my my dad was just kind of left alone to
be [ __ ] wild but my grandparents
would come in to also help like save the
day when you get into deep deep [ __ ]
yeah yeah but like like i told you my
dad got kidnapped once right
i don't think so yeah he got kidnapped
in downtown l.a
like back in the day by some gangsters
like
like my mom told me he was driving
downtown and this girl hollered at him
and
he and she got in the car with him and
she led him to the spot where he got
ambushed by two other dudes
and he just jacked his [ __ ] they jacked
his [ __ ] but they held him at knife
point and they had him call my grandpa
for ransom so my grandpa had to go in
there with a stack of cash to get my dad
out
that'd be so crazy yeah if like
your grandpa was just like
no thank you
[Laughter]
yeah no like so like
i see like the hardness and the [ __ ]
up [ __ ] that they've seen and been
through where it's just like as long as
we're not like him like i think my dad
was proud enough yeah i could see where
my dad didn't want us to do the [ __ ] he
used to do
so my my brother got a
cl type s back in high school
right
and you know kids with the fast car yeah
yeah so
um
uh i think it was when my brother got
his first speeding ticket or some [ __ ]
my dad once again lecturing us for hours
right
but we also know this story we know that
um
my mom said like try to tell us a story
how my dad used to have this
red camaro
right in the early 80s and like
used to [ __ ] drive the [ __ ] out of
that thing in k-town like loud v8 and
everything
and one day one of his kk buddies like
hey
you know can i borrow your car
and then he crashed and died speeding
yeah holy [ __ ] dude and so
we and so my we were trying to argue
back like i got but like because he was
also telling us like don't let
other people drive the car and [ __ ] too
and they're like you let your friend
drive your car and he crashed it he's
like exactly that's why i don't want you
to do it and then he said
my friend
bowled my car when i went to church
and then he
sped that car into the church wall to
commit suicide
like
am i i'm like
yeah this is [ __ ] up like
this guy borrowed my dad's car to kill
himself but he did it where my dad was
at
where he was going to be holy [ __ ] yeah
that's traumatic trump addict as [ __ ] so
that's why he's just like
you know you [ __ ] take care of this
yeah yeah nobody else drives your car
you don't [ __ ] race your car like
none of that [ __ ]
that's [ __ ] crazy yeah and your dad
just stuffed that [ __ ] his feelings
inside yeah and then he took it right
back in yeah and he beat your cry about
it
didn't even cry about it
it's like what do you mean my dad cries
dude i've only saw my dad cry once and
that's when my brother told him that um
not to call him um it's like don't say
that i'm your that you're my father
anymore and then my dad
ball dude like i remember he just he
literally walked to the couch
covered his eyes and he started bawling
like
and then i just remember my brother my
mom looked at my brother just like
disappointed and my brother started
tearing up he walks over to my dad and
just lays on his stomach and he starts
crying and i just remember looking at
that coin you know i said the same thing
and you kicked me out
[Laughter]
there was no core memory
there was no inside out [ __ ]
i was so
pissed
you're like this third-party viewer of
this core memory being built but it's
like a different color in your head
i just remember
watching these two sobbing cry together
right and then my mom walks over and
puts her her hand on my brother's
shoulder and i'm just standing there in
my boxers and my shirt going what the
[ __ ] is
this beautiful family moment
i remember standing there in my boxers
and my shirt going what what the [ __ ]
yeah you would have called me gay
i remember the time i was like hey don't
don't i guess you're not my dad anymore
he goes good
[Laughter]
we get out good job get out the [ __ ] is
up with this firstborn favoritism in our
families bro
it's so regular in korean families
though
i just remember i will forever remember
watching my dad cry for the first time
and it was over something i said to my
dad and he literally kicked me out yeah
but then the firstborn son